here's what would happen if humans had a  mating season if humans were like deer  women would only have two days a year  with the chance to get pregnant this  means women may need a lot of  mindfulness and yoga to get their bodies  in the mood because it can take 29  longer to get pregnant if you're  stressed mating with different partners  could also become a way to lower that  pressure  but not all humans would have the same  Mating Season or ritual the northern and  southern hemispheres would likely have  opposite mating seasons  then females who got pregnant would get  together and wait nine months for their  babies to develop when the time came all  the babies would be born within a period  of 10 days remember how one man would be  able to mate with different women well  that means most of us would grow up in  massive families like birds luckily this  isn't the case because